Ceci est en fait une présentation de deux heures que je donne aux lycéens,
résumé ici en trois minutes,
Tout a commencé un jour dans un avion, alors que j'allais à TED,
il y a sept ans.
Et dans le siège à côté de moi
il y avait une lycéenne, une adolescente,
et elle venait d'une famille vraiment pauvre.
Et elle voulait faire quelque chose de sa vie,
et elle m'a posé une simple petite question.
"Qu'est ce qui amène à la réussite?", m'a t'elle demandé
Et je me suis vraiment senti mal,
car je ne pouvais lui fournir une bonne réponse.
Donc je sors de l'avion, et je viens à TED.
Et je pense, bon sang, je suis au milieu d'une pièce remplie de gens qui ont réussi!
Pourquoi ne pas leur demander ce qui a contribué à leur réussite,
et je le transmettrai aux enfants?
Donc nous voici, sept ans, et 500 interviews plus tard,
et je vais vous dire ce qui conduit vraiment à la réussite
et fait vibrer les membres de TED
Et la première des choses c'est la passion
Freeman Thomas a dit: "Je suis poussé par la passion."
Les membres de TED le font par amour, et non pour l'argent.
Carol Coletta le dit: "Je paierai quelqu'un pour faire ce que je fais."
Et le plus intéressant c'est que,
si vous le faites par amour, l'argent viendra de toute manière.
Travail! Rupert Murdoch m'a dit, "Tout est un dur labeur.
Rien n'est facile. Mais je m'amuse beaucoup."
A t'il parlé d'amusement? Rupert? Oui!
Les membres de TED s'amusent en travaillant. Et ils travaillent dur.
J'en conclue, qu'ils ne sont pas des malades du travail, mais des malades de l'amusement.
Bien! Alex Garden a dit: "Pour réussir concentrez-vous sur quelque chose
et excellez dans ce domaine."
Il n'y a pas de magie, c'est de la pratique, encore de la pratique, et encore de pratique.
Et c'est la concentration. Norman Jewison m'a dit:
"Je pense que tout cela tient au fait de savoir vous concentrer sur une seule chose"
Et poussez! David Gallo a dit: "Efforcez vous.
Physiquement, mentalement, vous devez pousser, pousser, pousser."
Vous devez pousser au dela de la timidité et du doute personel.
Goldie Hawn a dit:"J'ai toujours eu des doutes sur moi même.
Je nétais pas assez bonne, je n'étais pas assez intelligente.
Je ne pensais pas que j'allais y arriver."
Bien sur ce n'est pas toujours facile de se pousser soi même,
et c'est pour cela que les mères ont été inventées. (Rires)
Frank Gehry -- Frank Gerhy m'a dit:
"Ma mère m'a poussé."
Servir! Sherwin Nuland m'a dit: "C'était un privilège de servir en tant que médecin."
Bien sur un tas de gosses me disent qu'ils veulent devenir millionaires.
Et la première chose que je leur dit c'est:
"OK, et bien vous ne pouvez pas vous servir vous même,
vous devez servir les autres en leur apportant quelque chose qui a de la valeur.
Car c'est ainsi que les gens deviennent riches."
Idées; Bill Gates membre de TED a dit: "J'avais une idée --
créer la première entreprise de logiciel pour micro ordinateurs."
Je dirai que c'était une sacrée bonne idée.
Et il n'y a aucune magie à la créativité pour obtenir des idées,
C'est juste de faire des choses très simples.
Et je donne quantité de preuves
Persévérer. dit Joe Kraus:
"La persévérance est la raison numéro une de nos succès."
Vous devez persévérer en dépit de l'échec. Vous devez persévérer au milieu du merdier."
Ce qui signifie bien entendu: "la Critique, le Rejet, les Trous Duc et la Pression."
(Rires)
Donc, la grande -- la réponse à cette question est simple:
Payez 4,000 balles et venez à TED.
Ou si vous vous ratez, faites ces huit choses -- et faites moi confiance,
ce sont les huit choses qui mènent à la réussite.
Merci membres de TED pour toutes vos interviews!